hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the United States Championship
2018 we have a game between Samuel
Shanklin than the Wunderland going into
the final round
Samuel Shanklin is leading the
tournament would have a point ahead of
world chess championship challenger
Fabiana Caruana and if he wins this game
then he's the leader he wins this
tournament and regardless of all the
other results so before I actually show
you the game we do have a nice photo of
them there is GM Sam Franklin and GM I
wonder Liang and as you're enjoying this
photo I do want to mention in in one of
my previous videos I did ask you if you
remembered when was the last game
Dingley were and lost in classical time
format and I told you the last game
Dingley when lost was against LaVon
Oregon in the World Cup in Belize
Georgia 2017 when in fact that is not
true which is which is kind of
embarrassing because I even researched
the matter and actually thought that was
the game but that was also a game in
rapid time format the the last hinting
leerin lost was not in September was
actually in August 2017 and he lost the
game against onigiri so yeah just so you
know that you know so you can when
you're trying to impress your friends
with your vast knowledge so you don't
impress them with with you know
misleading information so that being
said let's see this game link our sorry
Shanklin has the white pieces and he
opens with efore and it's quite an
interesting game at one moment there is
a certain move that can really like
crush the position and Shanklin misses
it like okay it's not it's not really a
simple move like he missed in his game
against one issue but but you'll see and
it's it's it's actually a very nice
puzzle for you to solve
we have c6 the caro-kann defense d4 d5
and D captors and e5 the exchange
variation C captors on d5 and Bishop to
d3 knife to c6
we have c3 Knight to f6 and the bishop
to f4 do Rubinstein variation of the
exchange caro-kann
Bishop to g4 attacking the Queen Queen
to b3 now pressuring the b7 pawn and
here comes a 5 this is a
this is a very double-edged move it
gives a white a whole lot of options and
it's a very brave for a young link to
play something like this against the the
leader of the tournament but the problem
is this move was already played I I
think I've seen just 24 posted that it
was already played eight times before
this game even in the wayy versus David
Navarro match so Shanklin was very much
prepared for this you have to react of
course if you capture with the bishop
then black will simply capture your
bishop deaths you know fine for black if
you capture with the pawn then Knight h5
again goes for your bachelor pad for you
Moon Knight captures on e5 you never
gain really anything by capturing this
b7 pawn then comes Ruby eight and then
the b2 point is under attack
so after this if I've moved Shanklin was
prepared and he played h3
instantaneously
we had pawn captures on a four pawn
captures on g4 and now Queen to e7
checked and King to f1 if you see a
position like this you know there's a
king and f1 the whole position looks
rather you know disturbing you might
think eleven our union is playing this
game but you know when you're well
prepared you're always you know you can
always play positions like this and this
game was already played between
grandmasters demchenko and your seven
and here Knights the e4 was played but
in this game liang leaves this game and
she plays queenside castle so now we
have a completely new game knife the d2
by Shanklin and now comes g6 of course
you can't capture on g4 if you capture
them better up to five checks you lose
the night I just in case any of you were
wondering g6 would have rook to e1
attacking the Queen Queen to c7 and now
g5 kicking the night away Knight to h5
and we have Bishop to e2 now threatening
to capture on h5 Knight comes to g7
Knight G to f3 and night to e6
Bishop to b5 now Franklin will transfer
the play over to the Queen side Bishop
to g7 and Queen to a for preparing ideas
like rush of captures on c6 perhaps and
grabbing the a 7-point rock 2d6
now that idea wouldn't really work
because if you captured and wrote
capture screen captors and then rook to
a6 would kind of trap the queen so that
we you know let's say if you even played
this then rock a6 and this queen is kind
of trapped you don't really have a way
to get out
you'd have to capture and that's just
losing for white so I have to look to
these six we have Knight to b3 and the
b6 Asics was a much better move that
would would have given Lee and better
chances but he plays b6 and he wants to
keep everything intact and now Shanklin
plays a move that you all know it's the
hardest move to find as eventually would
say he plays nice to see one the idea is
knighted e3 bringing right over to b4
and from there he will either force this
knife the catcher is opening up the C
file or this night will have some
excellent squares on a six or even
capturing and c6 so night the b8
we have night to d3 King Tubby seven and
night now does come to be for Queen to
d8 we have Knight to e5 Queen goes back
lien waits for four shank winds to show
what he's gonna do
also the Queen out defense the f7 pawn
Queen to b3 and rook F to D 8 we have
rook captures on h7 lien gives up a pawn
to activate his pieces and now you have
to be careful ideas like for for example
if this Knight moves then this rook
anyone can capture the night and the
night is defending the bishop so you do
have to do something about this first a
six kicking away the bishop will have
Bishop to d3 and now comes King to a 7
Queen to a four attack attacking the a6
square we have a five and now Bishop to
b5 King back to b7 and this is the
position I really wanted you to pause
the video and really try to find it the
move Shanklin in this position played
another Knight move Knight B to D 3 he
retreated with the knight back and this
is for example one one example that
does not agree with Chucky's Chucky's
idea feel free to pause the video here
and find the strongest attacking idea
for white it's a very it's a very strong
move as Shankly did miss it
a very powerful engine idea if you if
you if you will but you know as you know
there is something in the position
Shanklin didn't know so you know you
have the advantage there if we want to
try and find it I will give it a couple
of seconds for you to pause it so for
those of you who found that
congratulations you are an excellent
player you know finding such nice engine
ideas the idea is a Bishop to e8
attacking the f7 pawn now Knight
captures on f7 is a threat and it's okay
to give up your B for Knight temporarily
because after Knight captures on f7 then
blacks position simply falls apart
because the f7 point is defending the
knight here the knight is defending the
bishop here after the knight capture
both rooks will be under attack so for
example after pawn captures Knight which
is the strongest move Knight captures on
f7 now both of your looks are under
attack and after you play something you
can even throw in in between move let's
say captures captures and then rub the
d7 you have to play something there
really is no better move Bishop captures
rook captures and now rook captures on
e6 as we said the f7 pawn was defending
the knight Knight rook captures here and
now Queen to e8 and although black does
have two pieces for a rook he's
completely tied down and he doesn't
really have a useful move you can't
develop the knight you lose the rook if
you play Knight to c6 rook captures then
Queen captures rook here there's really
nothing to play after you exchange
Queens or if you capture with the rook
let's say look at your captors here
Bishop moves and now captures captures
and now you still have two pieces for
the rook but White has this past pawn
and at I mean soon very soon
black will have to give up this Bishop
for opponent and it's a completely
winning endgame I'll rock against a
knight being up 2 points so this is one
of the ways to do this but it doesn't
matter if you found all of this it's
important that you find Bishop create
that your intuition is in the right
place and then
halation will follow you know with time
and improvement a but in the game night
B 2 D 3 by Shanklin we have rook to b8
now defending that bishops of the knight
can move Knight to f3 and now Rock to h8
offering a trade of rocks rock captures
Bishop captures and now we have a three
Knight to c6 and Bishop captures on c6
liing plays rook captures on c6 Queen
captures on c6 is also an idea but it's
not it's not as great because then it's
a pretty forced variation Queen captures
rook captures and Knight to e5 going for
the f7 point it doesn't matter if you
exchange the bishop for night
immediately but the knight is much
stronger than the bishop so why not
Bishop captures Knight captures and now
after you defend the f7 pawn I white
will grab it all the same row captures
and you simply grab the piece and you're
up only one point but your jeep on
although it's a double point the g5 one
is far advanced and black has to play
route g7 to defend this pawn and this
rock is pretty much out of the game so
white will have no problems going
kingi to king f3 okay you can go there
but you can capture on f4 and then you
know just bring your king all the way up
there and then win the game so after
Bishop captures on c6 rook captures on
c6 and now Knight to e5 Bishop captures
Knight captures and rook to d6 and Queen
to e8 finally Shanklin infiltrates the
position
rook to d8 attacking the Queen Queen
captures on f7 Queen Knight captures and
g5 first and now Queen captures exchange
in Queens King captures and Knight
captors and g6 so if you look at the
position now Shanklin is up two points
and in a game of this level two points
in a in an endgame is too much
we have f3 trying to give up this eye a
single point for for at least not
allowing Shangguan to have two points
Knight to f4 we have king to c6 and a
pawn captures and Knight captures and
rook the d6 check kink the b5 and now
King to e to bring his King over into
the position Knight to g1 checked and
king to the three and after King today
this is a move 43 young Grandmaster
wonderly and resigned the game he
resigned the game okay it's maybe you
think yeah why not play on but there
really isn't anything to do white
White's definitely winning the d5 pawn
and that's just it whatever black plays
for example Knight to f3
you can simply capture this pawn there's
no way to defend it and after you
capture simply push c4 King has to move
and then pawn captures and then it's
it's again a rock against tonight you're
just gonna march or pawn up the board
and win the game abut pretty much
whatever whatever you play that doesn't
really help black so yeah now that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it it's an
excellent victory for Samuel Shanklin I
mean winning a tournament where World
Chess Championship challenge or Fabiana
Caruana played half a point ahead of him
and also let's not forget Wesley so
played here Hikaru Nakamura played here
and we don't have the final standing so
let's check that out as well so Seminole
Shanklin first place with eight and a
half out of 11 six wins 0 losses and 5
draws quite a result then Fabiano
Caruana in 2nd with 6 wins 1 loss
against via di Soria so yes we had kind
of did ruin that tournament for Fabiano
4 draws Wesley so in third with 6 and a
half then with 5 and a half we have
Alexandre Lenderman and Hikaru Nakamura
with 5 Jeffrey's young and via di Soria
then with foreign half a wonder link in
the aerosols Arabic also Vajrasana
Coughlin is here with 4 and a half and
Ray Robson and in last place with 3
points Alexander oh nice joke so yeah
those are those are the standings if we
have yeah only only Wesley so and Samuel
Shanklin are undefeated
so yeah it's I mean it's a it's a
wonderful victory for him and I mean an
excellent tournament all all in all so
it's interesting that I thought it'd be
nice that we covered that
Shanker chess tournament the Kashima
memorial and the US Championships
simultaneously because there we have the
world champion here we have the world
championship challenger and their cousin
did win his tournament here for we all
failed cannot win
tournament but you know the performance
Samuel Shanklin performed here in this
tournament is outrageous he was his his
rating performance was I don't think it
was but almost twenty nine hundred so
that's that's pretty insane but yeah
maybe maybe a small more you know
psychological victory for Colson as
their as they're nearing their match in
November so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed enjoyed it
congratulations once again stood to
those of you who found that move later
today I have I have a very special game
plan for you I do hope you will enjoy
that one as well it's kind of played by
by a celebrity so to say and then I will
have a poll and you will decide well
yeah you can share your votes and your
thoughts on which series do we cover
next do we go all the way to a yeah
hidden kappa blanka do we follow
Fischer's path to do the chest Olympus
or what's our next stop so thank you for
watching as usual you can check to my
previous videos here and I will see you
soon have a have a great rest of the day